hello everybody my
hi
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to
mannequin house
now if you know me i don't like
mannequins i don't think that they're
great i don't think they're cool i don't
like anything about him so why not play
a game just about mannequins and
mannequins in a house and a house full
of mannequins because that's what i want
to do
first thing in the morning by the way
the first week of filming of the sequel
for a heist with markiplier's gun so
it's uh very exciting
oh boy
so considering that i woke up it means
that i chose to be in this house full of
mannequins which i'm assuming that it is
judging by the name of this game so
either i saw the mannequins all the way
in or the mannequins have invaded my
home
and i don't like either of those options
because one says that i'm kind of stupid
and the other says that i'm kind of
being attacked by mannequins
hello
hi
how are we doing this fine
evening i'm
guessing
hi
so when did the mannequins start jumping
out of me that's what i would like to
know okay
[Music]
i don't like that bathroom
i don't have a flashlight
don't know why i decided to close myself
in here
hmm hello
don't like it
i don't like that at all i don't like
that none i don't like the layout of
this house i don't like anything about
it
good great grand
great good stuff
this is great
this is good stuff
okay yeah okay i don't like you getting
quiet
i don't want i don't like anything
that's going on right now because
like it's
it's not a joke that i don't like
mannequins it's not that mannequins
themselves just automatically scare me
it's just they're unsettling
and so i don't like the idea that i'm
gonna turn a corner and come face to
face with any sort of a mannequin
was that like that before i thought this
was wait no
was this like this before
[Music]
that's fine
that's fine that's fine
[Applause]
i mean it would have been weird without
that string playing behind me
but whatever cool accentuate the fact
that i just looped back to the bottom
floor of this house that's fine
all right before i go in there
for some reason
all right why is there a window there i
guess that's not too illogical i'm gonna
check out the bathroom again
because for some reason i do this to
myself
okay we're fine
one of these days that's not going to be
fine that's going to not be fine hello
this looks like a brightly lit living
room
i am excited about this
and the prospects that it holds for me
this is something i should read daily
news breaking news breaking news okay
okay so everything seems normal here
so far everything has been indeed normal
don't know if there's anything i was
supposed to find in here but i guess not
is anything gonna jump out at me
you know you never know with these
horror games whether it's just going to
build up a lot of atmosphere and tease
you with the idea that something's going
to jump out at you or
something's actually going to jump out
at you
if anything i kind of would prefer that
at this moment because maybe
i could uh
relax a little bit
[Music]
still don't like that
i still don't like that
one
did you close automatically before i
don't remember that happening
but maybe i wasn't paying attention
because of the door in front of me
opened and that was more of a pressing
concern
to me
at this juncture
oh
okay i don't know why i don't know why i
do this to myself
i hate shower curtains just in general
never liked them all right nothing out
of the ordinary
well it's a good thing mannequins don't
walk
or else that would be unnerving
oh my god
oh my
god
i thought i was gonna die i thought that
was it i thought i was done i put up
this piece of foam to try to block off
this big ass
wall in front of the actual
hvac oh my god i thought that was it
oh my god
i'm fine
now because it was dark and i saw
something coming at me i was like
this is where the guillotine built into
the laundrous drops and kills me
okay anyway yeah playing a game forgot
about that
kind of stumbling up these steps
why am i so stumbly jumbly
why am i stumbling jumbly
okay good
great
it's good stuff
hmm
[Music]
great you know for being called
mannequin house i'm not seeing a lot of
mannequins
kind of light on the mannequins you know
what i mean
there's something at the end of the
hallway no
no
all right time for this again why i
don't know
okay we're fine we're fine we're fine
do not know
[Music]
hi
it's dork
it's dork any mannequins in the dork i'm
gonna be really pissed if there's
not actually any man no i'm not gonna be
pissed at all actually
i take that
hey
hi how you doing you know what i'm
coming after you
no
okay
that's fine
it is after all the mannequin house so i
shouldn't exactly be surprised at the
presence
of mannequins in the mannequin house so
i would not be surprised
by that
at all
because
it is
perfectly normal
not going to go there
not going there
i don't like that that is locked
all right pal all right buddy
you want to throw down i'm watching this
phone
how you guys you good okay here we go
all right
great good this is exactly what i was
hoping for
i was hoping for exactly this
yes
excellent good
easy that level was easy i'm assuming
that every time i look through it's a
level
no not like this
no no
no this is the door that i go through
no
technically
i could
stop playing right now
i could do that i could do that i can do
that right now but i'm a big brave boy
okay who's in the darkness isn't
mannequin i'm gonna punch the first
thing i see i swear to god i will punch
i just will punch and i will not stop
punching i thought the candelabra was a
mannequin
well it's dark
and that's okay
what was that
oh do i get this is this mine now does
it stay as flickery as it ever was uh
you know light doesn't work that way
where it only goes a certain distance
and then just stops it actually keeps
going um
so you know
just in case you didn't know how that
worked well
at least having a flashlight is a little
bit of a comfort so please whatever you
do don't take it away from me or else
i'll be very extremely unbelievably
upset with you
okay
perfectly normal perfectly normal
perfectly normal i think if i was
actually in this situation the first
thing that i would do would be dive
through a window 100
straight up like it could just be a
normal power outage but if i saw a
mannequin in my house that wasn't
supposed to be there
window immediately
not gonna happen okay you
okay you don't you you can't get silent
like that you stay noisy
you say noisy as hell
well this is
this is just not fair it's not
fair is it
no
the answer is no okay
okay
oh you're open now all right i trust
this i trust this hmm
i trust this
i
i don't trust that
i don't trust that tall
that's normal none of this is normal why
am i trying to normal ah
[Laughter]
any of this
hello friend
how did you oh nice arm
you didn't tell me oh god oh my god oh
my god
i'm the one who built the mannequins
it's me
they're my babies
nah
i am the mannequin daddy i didn't
realize this
you know what frankly i'm glad that
bathroom's still locked i'm glad i'm
very glad
i'm actually not glad about any of this
but i am pretending to be glad
okay
um
what did i just see
i swear i saw something
i saw something
okay
normal looping or are you going to throw
me for a loop
ah
okay
i'm just checking behind me at regular
intervals because i can't trust anything
at this moment i trust nothing i trust
absolutely nothing
okay that's luck
oh no
hello hi how are you
great to see you great to see you the
gang's all here guys all right let's sit
down and watch this movie hey how you
doing hi how is you hey how are you ah
yeah it's a good painting snapped it
myself oh okay i'll see you around read
a book it'll learn you nice ass all
right goodbye i'm gonna close this you
you guys are having a great time so you
don't need me
interrupting this is good stuff this is
what people call the good stuff
this is good stuff
there's good stuff that's good stuff
it's good stuff oh not good stuff bad
stuff actually bad this is what people
refer to as the bad stuff
did you want me to come back down here
is this or something you wanted to share
with me
okay goodbye now farewell
still in here great i'm gonna i guess
help
me
it just wants me to go back and forth it
wants me to get my steps in for today
speaking of which did you
come on now
okay so either i'm missing something or
you know
i gotta go in that room with the
mannequins and maybe close the door on
myself and then i i can get used to them
i can get acclimated to the idea of
being in a room with mannequins hello
i'm here now
what is it
[Music]
oh
hello
yes showed you guys
ripped all your nugs clean off
well you didn't see that one coming you
know that's what you get
that's good you know
yeah you know
should have known better
you should have known better
mess with the likes of me
yeah
you know throw down with the best you
gotta be prepared
you gotta be ready to come at me full
strength because you know
better make sure i'm dead
that's all i gotta say about that
okay moving on trying to
like yeah get me out of here okay good
behind good
great
i
bet you heard what happened to your
friends you don't want to mess with me
how can i not go in there is am i not
allowed no bathroom breaks from
is it bathroom time for me is it is it
bathroom oh good great good this is
exactly what i was not
[Music]
okay
thank you for that thank you i needed to
go
hi
okay thank you yes thank you
hi hello how are you good see you good
good hello
can i am
good good good stuff good stuff good
stuff okay good great
oh well well don't mind me find all the
missing mannequin parts well if i just
rip them off of the other ones
i don't think i'm gonna have too much of
a problem i don't think anything's gonna
be too much of a problem for me
considering it seems like i built these
things can i borrow some
never mind apparently i don't need to
look at that ass
oh you were looking at me looking at
your eye
can i have this
okay
let's and the world record for the
fastest moonwalk goes to you
congratulations you won
there might have been a part upstairs
that i didn't see because i didn't feel
like staying in that room for very long
time but
if i don't find them all down here then
i will just go back upstairs i'm
guessing that they've actually hidden
them
oh there we go okay that's one arm i'm
guessing it's arm arm and a head
is that what we're missing
arm arm and a head maybe because the
head spun around that was like it's
saying hey it's this head that you need
maybe that's what it was all about
hi
you know this whole time i've been
eagerly awaiting someone to be behind
there but
now that you're actually here i'm not
quite oh not quite so afraid anymore so
thank you
hi
don't mind me
don't mind me hey what's up
okay
hello
uh-huh
i think that's all of them
i think i think that's all of them
okay you have fun sobbing
i will be doing the same very soon sorry
i left all these doors open let me just
get those real quick
and uh
i'll just be on my way guys
asthma's a hey what's up hey
well i found them all
don't know where i'm supposed to return
is anyone else just suddenly bleeding
from their eyeballs
great
okay
oh
hang on
let me make sure
i'm double checking
freedom
uh oh
hey high five bam
all right
freedom
oh no
oh no no
um
[Music]
i knew it i knew something was going to
appear behind me i oh
ah what a crazy dream
what a nut-so dream
good thing i'm all back home and safe
and sound
ah what a night guys what a night but we
made it through we survived one could
say we escaped the night
oh freedom
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
that was great
i hated it
and therefore it was a good horror game
good job
that was awful for me to experience but
the game itself was great so yeah that's
mannequinhouse you can play this for
yourself if you want link is in the
description
thank you all so much for
making such wonderful games
such as this
hope you have a great day if you want
more scary games that i played the link
is in the description or their suggested
videos you know where they are
have a good day take care and as always
i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]